les citations des héros le mot juste
pour décrire les à 17 ans les jumeaux
massinissa et gaia 16 ans qui ont
contribué à sauver une vie c'est comme
quelque chose de normal sûr que
n'importe qui aurait fait peut-être la
même chose on voit le monde un parterre
simple normal d'essayer de l'aider 4
décembre dernier à l'école secondaire
georges vanier de montréal une
enseignante de français perd conscience
durant son court on a vu qu'elle ne
respire pas et il n'y a pas de pour une
autre enseignante court chercher de
l'aide dans une autre classe comme même
aux freins et sauveteurs ben on est allé
dans sa classe j'ai pensé que c'était
une blague
là j'ai vu mon frère commencé à courir
quand j'ai vu le visage de la preuve je
me suis directement que c'était pas
d'une blague quand je les ai vus partir
au début j'ai paniqué un petit peu après
je me suis dit que c'était vraiment peur
mais après j'ai dit que non je vais
mettre tout à côté et je vais aider les
trois ont suivi la formation rcr
réanimation cardiorespiratoire on avait
l'hypothèse que elle et elle s'était
elle s'était étouffé donc on a commencé
directement avec les compressions m'a
pas fait de l'inflation
j'attendais intercom qu'on appelait
qu'elle est professeur qu'elle n'est pas
bien de monter rapidement avec là encore
des élèves dans la classe des
secouristes puis j'ai qui dit qu'ils
étaient un contrôle dans leur façon de
communiquer entre eux en regarde c'est
un tournant les manipulateurs on attend
ça nous indique un besoin d'un choc
qu'ont fait les chocs et puis on
continue jusqu'à l'arrivée des premiers
répondants
aujourd'hui l'enseignant de 65 ans est
toujours hospitalisée mais elle va mieux
chaque minute compte c'est sûr qu'en fin
de séance bien humblement
ils remercient leurs parents de les
avoir incités à suivre la formation
mon père ma famille en après que si
quelqu'un veut l'aide on l'aide quelque
chose d'important de prendre un cours de
premiers surtout ils ont contribué à
sauver une vie ils disent qu'ils n'ont
fait leurs devoirs ici vers les rues
michaela bayne radio canada montréal